they couldn't get answers in the UK they
hope it will be different three and a
half thousand miles away they want to
meet answer coulis who killed their son
Harry Dunne in a collision then claimed
diplomatic immunity and left the country
her lawyer says that misses sir coulis
sends her sympathy and apologies
yes it's some start of some closure
having said that as it's nearly seven
weeks now since we lost our boy sorry
just doesn't cut it
the crash happened outside RAF croton in
Northamptonshire an American spy base
it's where answer Kulas as husband a US
diplomat was stationed in a letter to
Harry's family the Foreign Secretary
changed his stance and said that mrs.
cyclists no longer had diplomatic
immunity because she'd gone home the US
he said agreed after thinking about the
letter obviously we were right from the
start so here we are about to get onto
the plane at Heathrow to go to America
still apprehensive because you don't
this thing has been up and down up and
down but hopefully hopefully you all get
the answers we are seeking the family
who have never accepted that answer
cool-ass had diplomatic immunity have
planned a number of TV interviews with
US networks starting in New York whether
they meet answer coulis or not Harry's
family are convinced that the laws
surrounding diplomatic immunity need to
be changed so that this never happens
again
they're also exploring all of their
legal options missus akula's could come
back voluntarily to assist police with
their inquiries although her lawyers are
likely to advise her not to if she's
charged with an offense in the UK then
the British government could apply for
her extradition it would be for a US
Court to decide whether there are
reasonable grounds to believe she's
committed a crime but her defense team
may argue that she had diplom
to community at the time of the alleged
offense and so cannot be tried in the UK
and while Harry's parents cannot file
criminal proceedings in America there is
a possibility the family could pursue a
civil case mrs. siccola says lawyer says
she will now cooperate something
Northamptonshire police have welcomed I
would like to be able to speak to the
driver about this incident we would like
to be able to progress this
investigation regardless of by the means
with which that's achieved it is
absolutely essential for us to be able
to effectively progress this
investigation to a conclusion for
Harry's family Harry's parents and their
many supporters will not let this drop
they've come too far for that
Lisa Dowd Sky News New York